ça c'est un porte-avions 2010 et un
ascenseur
on met l'avion dessus et décembre c'est
bien nos soldats orange une citrouille
tu devrais compter à ma confiture de
fraises aux escargots de bourgogne
elle est excellente à limonade orange a
des gars tout tient bon jour vous
arrivez en plein boom
la fête bat son plein excusez-moi j'ai à
faire
regarde c'est oiseaux comme il est beau
eric soumettrait sa gamme ont joué ces
dix neuf bonjour monsieur le président
je ne supporte pas d'entendre ce mot
veut pas entendre ce que disent les
grincheux grincheux mois alors ça si moi
je suis un gars vraiment bien ma charge
ils sont très nombreux passagers rien
chercher du taf au pardon monsieur le
président ce n'est rien de tout elle
vous le rendra service monsieur le
président je dois aller de ce côté-ci
vérifié chez les affiches de la fête ont
bien été posée et d'autre part j'ai
rendez vous ici même avec le photographe
pour qu'il fasse mon portrait alors ce
n'est pas trop vous demander qu ils vous
attendent
c'est cela merveilleux ma très chère
amie vous avez d'une telle unité légende
d'une rapidité exemplaire pour tout à
l'heure 1
pour être honnête ça va être trop l'oeil
de quoi parles-tu casimir
je n'imagine rien de plus n'est qu'une
photo de monsieur du snop maintien
justement voilà le photographe messieurs
mademoiselle drot salut bonjour
salut salut dites-moi est-ce que cette
pause la hjra vous préférez ça a
peut-être non alors ça c'est très
gracieux en effet mais je suis ici pour
photographier le président ira que vous
l'attendiez mais très bien je l'attends
dit soyez gentils prenait quand même une
photo d'eux kazimierz ça lui ferait
tellement plaisir
monsieur du snop sera furieux mais je me
chargerai d'éloigner des couleurs
photographier ça vous laissera le temps
de faire un cliché de casino c'est
d'accord pour m
je bête à bien l'écouter c'est que je
désirerais conserver sur mon clichés
l'ambiance de la fête
alors comment mais vous voulez me mettre
mais le tout le monde ne verra pas non
non non non non c'est à dire que je veux
tout le monde dans le fonds et vous ici
devant très gros plan c'est à dire
qu'ils seront dans le fond mais en tout
petit et vous votre visage devant en
très gros à ses parts c'est après voilà
vos plans ne bougez pas peur fait merci
un bonjour merci beaucoup vous fait
passer les clichés dès qu'ils se
reprennent et bien sûr merci vous dites
monsieur lice nabawi julie et moi nous
voudrions vous montrer quelque chose
mais cette fois ce n'est pas très loin
je suis parti j'ai fais rien je vais où
il faut cela fait partie de ma fonction
de quoi qu'est ce que c'est
qasimi revenez vite ça qu'est ce qu'il
est je vais vous prendre une photo oui
mais ce n'est pas possible pas avec cet
appareil maintenant mais pourquoi quand
ils m'ont appareils mais parce que après
le gros plan que vous avez fait de
monsieur du snop toute la pellicule doit
être abîmée vous n'allez pas croire
cette légende mais véhicule est en
excellente état
bon ne bougeait pas voilà comme ça ça va
oui ce sera une photo superbe ray non ça
ne va pas le cas at il encore je
voudrais un gros plan a comme monsieur
deux hommes n'ont plus gros non non non
encore plus gros donc encore encore non
je voudrais un très très gros plans oui
mais je veux être trop près mais non
c'est ma foot ou alors ça ne paie rien
allez allez avancer encore encore encore
écouter ces grands encore encore vous
l'aurez voulu
oui mais ce sera un vrai gros plans voie
[Musique]
là
à
oh la la la la la la mais qu'est ce
qu'il fait il est en retard il m'avait
promis de m'apporter ma photo les
casseurs epr ait enfin casimir casimir
t'énerve pas comme ça faut du temps tu
sais pour développer une photo bah tiens
d'ailleurs voilà le photographe
ah voilà votre photo casimir comme je
vous l'avais dit pour un gros plan c'est
très gros plan qu'est-ce que ça la
pellicule était mauvaise
non mais casimir a voulu un tellement
gros plan que je n'ai réussi à
photographier son ventre mais merci
quand même
au revoir au revoir eddy dont casimir
comment vas tu faire tu voulais vendre
ta faute aux enchères je suis venu
assister à cette vente comique à vous
voulez acheter la photo de casimir
jamais mon ami jamais je n'achèterai une
photo de ce monstre et ça je vous le
promets quoi moi un monstre
or peut-on voir la photographie non elle
n'est pas encore là à dommage j'aurais
bien ri mais qu'est ce que ceux-ci
confus mais où avez vous trouvé ça ce
tableau abstrait est admirable c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre de l'art contemporain
je peux l'acheter ben si vous voulez
bien
200 francs ça suffit non 205 je peux pas
t'empêcher de marchander toi tiens merci
et 5,5 france les cinq balles à sa merci
bon mes amis je vous laisse je vais
mettre ce chef-d'oeuvre chez moi vous me
donnerez le nom du fou qui achètera la
photo de casimir si vous y tenez
monsieur les snobs avec les villes
promet ce que tu vas faire de tout cet
argent est bien puisque mon ventre est
un chef-d'oeuvre
je vais acheter un cadre pour l'encadrer
casimir
[Musique]